[Musique]
le 12 avril dernier le comédien
scénariste et réalisateur aussi simon
olivier fecteau s'est vendu d'une
publication sur facebook qu'on voit ici
piqué au vif par la désinformation
qu'ils voyaient circuler sur le web
il l'étalé de cette montée de lait dont
l'oeil qui a généré plus de 10000
partagent plus de 6000 commentaire on a
voulu chasser un peu de tout ça avec lui
parce que ce n'est pas fini
il en a rajouté par la suite publication
après publication simon olivier fecteau
bas d'abord un gros merci de la part de
toute l'équipe d'accepter notre
proposition
cette proposition de jasette qu'on va
voir toi et moi ensemble aujourd'hui
pourquoi tu as décidé de dénoncer ce qui
se dit est ce qui s'écrit à tort et à
travers dans ce contexte de pandémie
qu'est-ce qui est venu chercher au
départ et il coûte 10 complète si
c'était un complot au nouveau conseil
depuis la pandémie
on dirait qu'une multiplication kim gye
dans la famille mots j'ai des gens qui
croient aux théories de conspiration sur
les gens que j'aime c'est démonter mal
vivre et quelle terrible conspiration
qui très adepte de ce pays mais je suis
toujours à des encore est lui qui manie
je pense que je me serais bien 4 heures
du matin temps pandémie fait chi recul
tant pis j'ai reçu des coups cela dit je
pense des courriels avec des vidéos du
monde juniors qui se passe il est assez
llosa c'est la folie de croire n'importe
quoi qui a fait que j'ai dit j'ai juste
écrit un post très très très sentie sans
filtre et demie viala parce que beaucoup
de gens qui qui pensait ce qu'il y avait
ce que quelqu'un peut le j'ai insulté
beaucoup personne en disant croire
n'importe quoi j'ai insulté beaucoup de
gens puissent au jeu mais ce que je peux
insulter les gens je pense que c'est un
moment pour ses insultes entre nous puis
je suis d'accord avec ça mais mais ce
caramel important d'amener mettre son
pied à terre comme waouh ça fait pas de
sens parce qu'un élément particulier qui
déclare quelque chose en toi un élément
de leur discours kit et hérite le plus
sookie thème der meij plus donc toujours
tout le monde a droit à son opinion puis
on respecte beaucoup de différences
d'opinion mais un certain moment donné
même si on peut respecter coûte légères
différences d'opinion je pense qu'il
faut se rappeler aux vérifier d'où ses
opinions le vienne puis de mettre
importante sur les experts c'est qu'un
médecin ou un scientifique où ça fait 20
ou 30 ans qui fait son métier à tous les
jours qu'ils étudient dans piques et à
semelle long du jeu ce qui fait pis que
tu t'obstines avec quelqu'un qui est
faite trois jours de recherches sur
youtube puis je vis des vidéos qui ont
changé sa vie et là ce que je mettais
pas les mêmes compétences
6 comme c'est quoi ils ont théorique une
impasse et maintenant quitter
complètement fausse
mais de nos oreilles impliqué mettant
dans un complot pour tuer 3000
américains pendant 70 ça c'est pas comme
si tu mets là existe pas ces monstres
moi j'utilise cellario l'invité gg je
veux ça fait partie de mon travail quand
j'écris ce personnage le d'un président
du syndic issues sont propres ça fait
pas de sens
ça fait pas de sens oui mais le monde
plus gros mensonge plus gros le monde
non non non non on est assez garder un
supporter en six personnes qui aiment
allier quelqu'un qui s'éveille de la
personne le serrage les yeux parce que
l'autre me dit assem garde et un complot
500 personnes et plus dépité c'est
impossible c'est impossible
puis je comprends pas pourquoi les gens
qui autorise complot croit dit situation
oui mais ce que quelqu'un qui dirige les
médias ont pas doit peser ce qui demande
aux médias pas dit certaines choses
virgin media tout le monde les
formations sont au repos
ils m'ont dit tu peux un média comme un
humain amplement c'est peut-être un
petit coup du mec le marché un journal
comme on dit diddy position politique
claire des médias par commettre des
erreurs parfois ce temps lui aussi aussi
aussi pu en avoir
après ce deux jours plus tard la comaga
monument non limitions peut-être pas
fait le rhum le maire de leurs travers
ce qu'on veut mais une énorme différence
entre ce depuis on va vous manquer il ya
un vaccin qui existent ont le podium
personne mais parce qu'on veut
éventuellement contrôler mais je
t'écoute le rex l'olivier est ce que je
dois mais qui est pris pour ton moral ou
est ce que ton esprit bis mais existent
encore qu'est ce qu'on fait comment tu
vois tu entrevoit les on veut notre
avenir collectif mois ci dessus qu'est
ce que je pense je ne te laisserai
pandémie - c'est vraiment un garçon si
je pense qu'on voit exactement et comme
à bâle la police fait je pense que dès
qu'on veut d'abord se créer des mesures
en cas de nouvelles paniques inapte à
des programmes plus clair mais côté des
nations et est coté aussi théorique
nationale on va rester bas et il pense
qu'elles assainissent dans le fond ce
comme un journaliste aux journalistes
mais dis moi c'est quelqu'un qui qui
remet en question les choses mais qui va
primer mais c'est ça même année c'est
comme la fin de la terre plati la faille
qui je me demande si mme et on suppose
au liban damas sont en cours entre la
table maintenant si cool but de nous
cacher ce que ça donne si ça c'est pas
vraiment beaucoup d'énergie le pour
cacher le fait la taille des plateaux
sipa c'est un job à temps plein dans
certains pays membres du personnel d'un
sèche cheveux lisses pense que le le
bureau de pour conserver le secret date
en plaques qui recense 500 employés top
secret parce que vraiment on a vraiment
ces moyens là c'est quoi le dos m moi
j'ai pas mal d'amis d'amis truc j'en ai
acheté c'est que si jamais un jour là je
me trompe halle puis finalement la peur
est à plat traitez moi qui dois je les
accepte
si tu vois pas d excuses aux gens
jean-jo m'excuser très mal appliquée mal
à s'en passer
écrire c'est fini ma pour ses précieuses
minutes de train de confinement que tu
nous as consacré puis bonne entre
l'équipe des décrypteurs bon courage
ensuite on travaille des décrypteurs en
guillemets surfer réseaux sociaux salut
et merci merci merci